on va commencer sur ses pieds là c'est
parti pour la récolte pour le cassis
tout commence dans les champs à conques
heures 5 hectares de l'exploitation sont
consacrés uniquement à ce petit fruit
rouge
ici on travaille en famille et en bio
pour cultiver le fruit mais aussi les
bourgeons a la particularité de produire
les fruits que l'on transforme donc tout
ce qui est cultivé ici sur nos terrains
et ramassé ensuite surgelés et puis
après rapporté petit à petit tout au
long de l'année à la ferme pour
fabriquer des produits qu'on voit en
direct
c'est seulement à un petit kilomètre
deschamps que tout se passe dans leur
atelier
il y a bien sûr la préparation d'un
grand classique la confiture mais aussi
des produits un peu plus surprenant
aujourd'hui c'est au tour du ketchup de
cassis de me jeter ça a été un virage
très important dans la femme très rouge
puisque c'est un produit ans quand on
l'a sorti en 2005 qu'a explosé en termes
de volume
moi je pense est fabriquée 300 pour
m'amuser et puis c'est un produit
aujourd'hui on fabrique des milliers
tous les ans
seule une petite partie de leurs fruits
et vendus notamment à de grands
restaurants à saulieu dans cette étoilé
au guide michelin
on utilise aussi la saveur de ce fruit
est ici il peut être cuisiné à toutes
les sauces
[Musique]
le chef réalise par exemple ou un filet
de canard au nectar jolie et bourgeons
de cassis j'ajoute la purée de
topinambours au cassis évidemment son
utilisation première c'est pour les
desserts on les sorbets des glaces des
entremets et puis dans le stalles et
parce que c'est un fruit d'une saveur
qui se marient remarquablement bien avec
volaille avec le boeuf et en salle
les clients sont ils convaincus par sept
accords subtils
le cassis moi je connais surtout dans le
cuir mais elle a travaillé au goût de la
cuisine c'est
mais la gastronomie reste une exception
pour ce fruit au musée du cassis ils
sont chaque année 40 milles à venir
découvrir les secrets d'un produit plus
populaires la traditionnelle liqueur ya
vingt ans les black eyed pour ces jeunes
canadiennes plus habitué au sirop
d'érable qu'à la crème de cassis la
découverte peut être surprenante glace h
he kahn't estates gens n'avaient jamais
goûté avant mais quand je rentrerai
j'essaierai sûrement d'en trouver
c'est plutôt pas mal cette liqueur on
pourrait mettre de la liqueur de cassis
sur la glace à la vanille ce serait très
beau mais juste à voir c'est très bien
aussi
aujourd'hui cette liqueur fait partie du
patrimoine français et c'est le fruit
d'une longue histoire
elle a pris son essor en france au tout
début du 20e siècle les liquoriste
dijonnais en profite et développe sa
production
puis c'est le chanoine kir député maire
de dijon qui va donner son nom à un
apéritif fait de vin blanc et de crème
de cassis une véritable aubaine pour la
filière
pour cet historien spécialiste de la
bourgogne c'est félix kir qui l'a
popularisé toute la france le monde
entier ne buvaient pas du pire c'est
petit à petit que la réputation du
chanoine a fait qu a fini par en boire
un peu partout et sur des cartes de
restaurants dans le monde entier vous
avez eu ce mot qui savent étonnant
aujourd'hui la filière produits 16
millions de bouteille de crème de cassis
chaque année pour un chiffre d'affaires
de 60 millions d'euros
une poignée d'entreprises se partagent
le marché en bourgogne le geda gouttes
vedrenne boudier briotet ou encore i
l'héritier guyot
c'est justement dans leurs usines
dijonnaise que la crème de cassis et
fabriquer tous les ans l'entreprise
utilise plus de 1000 tonnes de cette
petite baignoire
à 19 ans
le marché français représente encore la
majorité de ses ventes
mais l'héritier guyot a créé une marque
spécialement pour le marché allemand
avec une recette adapté aux habitudes
des consommateurs
alors celui là il a été fait la semaine
dernière
tirage est prévu l'entreprise compte
beaucoup sur l'export aujourd'hui
impossible pour elle de se passer de ce
débouché le développement dotation d'une
marque qui a une vocation internationale
c'est forcément l'export c'est
aujourd'hui effectivement la possibilité
de pouvoir développer non seulement la
crème de cassis de dijon mais également
la déclinaison des autres crèmes et puis
à des destinations comme la grande
bretagne ou les états unis voir l'asie
bien sûr qu'ils ont un potentiel encore
des développements importants pour
l'instant c'est au japon que la filière
exporte le plus de bouteille 3 millions
chaque année
vient ensuite l'allemagne 1 millions de
bouteilles autre marché un peu plus
modestes les états unis avec cent mille
bouteilles exportées tous les ans au
total en bourgogne les liquoriste en
vente 6 millions par an à l'étranger
mais la crème de cassis est elle
vraiment l'avenir pour cette filière
pour avoir notre réponse
nous sommes restés à dijon où la couleur
du cassis est présente partout
l'addition
[Musique]
dans cette école de commerce un
programme est dédié au marché du vin et
des spiritueux
et ici on compte encore sur cette
liqueur vous en avez ici ici ici ici on
doit en avoir une bonne dizaine en tout
pour le directeur les liquoriste
bourguignons n'ont pas le choix ils
doivent absolument se renouveler
proposer de nouveaux produits pour faire
face à la baisse de la consommation de
la crème de cassis sa consommation en
baisse depuis un certain nombre d'années
pour tout un tas de raison est liée
notamment aux changements de modes et
aux habitudes de consommation les
français consomment moins mais mieux
les fabricants de crèmes de cassis de
dijon et plus généralement au bourgogne
ont pris ce pari de la qualité et de la
montée en gamme
depuis maintenant un certain nombre
d'années et s'il a bien du cassis se
trouvait en fait ailleurs que dans le
fruit
au fil de notre reportage nous avons
découvert de nombreux produits
cosmétiques
élaboré à partir de bourgeon mais aussi
des produits pharmaceutiques
ce producteur a terminé sa récolte une
partie des bourgeons entreposées ici ils
iront bientôt dans des laboratoires pour
fabriquer des antidouleurs de nombreux
bourgs gens qui sont utilisés en
pharmacopée et le bourgeon de cassis en
fait partie on a démarré de pratiquement
zéro il ya une dizaine d'années ou
quinzaine d'années en arrière ça
n'existait pratiquement pas donc c'est
un marché qui est en développement
cd croissance relativement modestes
parce que les volumes restent modestes
mais bon c'est décroissance qui sont
souvent à deux chiffres d'une année sur
l'autre
une croissance qui pourrait porter cette
filière dans les prochaines années pour
le cassis l'avenir sera donc entre
tradition et modernité
[Musique]